This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Georgina.
With no end in sight to the coronavirus pandemic, many people can't wait for the year 2020 to end.
But with the coronavirus dominating the newspaper headlines,
attention has moved away from an equally serious global issue, which has quietly been getting worse.
Climate change.
August 2020 saw the hottest temperature recorded anywhere in modern times, 54.4 degrees Celsius
in California's Death Valley. The same month also saw record amounts of ice melting into the oceans
around Greenland and the Arctic. Huge icebergs breaking away from the edge of the ice sheet.
A thick layer of ice which has covered a large area for a long time.
Greenland's ice sheet is three times the size of Texas at almost two kilometres thick.
Locked inside is enough water to raise sea levels by six metres.
But global heating and melting polar ice has many scientists asking whether it's now too late to stop.
Have we reached the point of no return?
In this programme, we'll be looking at the effects of climate change on the Arctic and asking if
it's too late to change. And learning some of the related vocabulary too.
Now Georgina, you mentioned record levels of ice melt in the North Pole that the scale is hard
to take in. The amounts are so big they're measured in gigatons. That's a billion metric tons.
Imagine a giant ice cube one kilometre by one kilometre by one kilometre.
So my quiz question is this how many gigatons of ice are now melting into the ocean every year.
Is it A 450 gigatons, B 500 gigatons or C 550 gigatons?
I'll take a guess at B 500 gigatons.
Okay Georgina, we'll find out later. Now, Glaciologists, Michaela King, has been monitoring
the melting of Arctic ice by satellite. Here she is answering a question from BBC World
Service Programme Science in Action on whether the destruction of the ice sheet is now unavoidable.
If we were to say, you define a tipping point as a shift from one like stable dynamic state
to another, this certainly meets that criteria because we are seeing now that the ice sheet was more
less in balance prior to 2000 where the amount of ice being drained from the glaciers was
approximately equal to what we were gaining on the surface via snow every year.
Isis made from snow falling on greenlands, glaciers, large, slow moving masses of ice.
At the same time though, ice is also lost through melting.
These two processes of making and melting ice kept the ice level in balance,
having different parts or elements arranged in the correct proportions. Essentially,
the melting ice was replaced by newly frozen ice.
But now the glaciers are shrinking faster, the new ice is being accumulated,
and the situation may have reached a tipping point. The time at which a change or an effect
cannot be stopped. So does this mean that global heating and ice melting are now running
automatically separate from the amount of greenhouse gases humans are pumping into the atmosphere?
Does that mean we should just give up on the planet?
In fact, the situation is far from simple, as Michaela King explains here to BBC World Service Programme
Science in Action. We can definitely control the rate of mass loss, so it's definitely not a
throw your hands up and just not do anything about. Give up on the ice sheet kind of situation,
that's certainly not the message I want to send. But it does seem likely that we will continue
to lose mass, but of course, a slow rate of mass losses highly preferred to large annual losses
every year. Michaela thinks that changes in human activity can still slow the rate or speed at
which something happens. In this case, the speed of Greenland's ice sheet melting.
She's convinced it's not too late for collective action to save the planet, so it's not yet time
to throw your hands up, and idiom meaning to show frustration and despair when a situation becomes
so bad that you give up or submit. It's a positive message, but one which calls for everyone to do what
they can before it really is too late. Because the rate of ice melt is still increasing, right Neil?
Yes, that's right. In fact, that was my quiz question, Georgina, do you remember?
Yes, you asked me how many gigatons of Greenland's ice sheet are now melting every year. I said
be 500 gigatons. And you were? Correct. In fact, some of these giant ice cubes are like small towns
almost a kilometre tall. So there's still work to be done. In this program, we've been looking at the
rate or speed of ice melt in Greenland's ice sheet, the thick layer of ice covering a large area
of the Arctic. Previously, the melting ice was replaced by newly formed ice on glaciers,
large masses of slow moving ice. This kept the Arctic in balance, having different elements
arranged in proportion. But the effects of global heating have brought us close to a point of no
return called a tipping point, the time at which a change or an effect cannot be stopped.
The situation is serious, but there's still time to take action and not simply throw your hands up.
Show frustration and despair when you want to give up.
That's all for this program, but if you want to find out more about climate change in Greenland's
ice sheets, search BBC's Science and Action website. And for more trending topics and useful
for cabriory, remember to join us again soon at 6 Minute English, bye for now. Goodbye.